make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so getting back into remastering
our run-on Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers
I know we've taken a break for a while
it's been a while since we since we kind
of followed up on this but again we were
basically waiting for for the time being
right when like Avengers in game was
gonna come out to kind of segue into
this just to show you guys how great
Avengers stories can really be in Marvel
Comics but again there is a little bit
of catching up to do but the benefit of
where we stopped in terms of the
previous videos means that like we can
kind of just you know segue directly
into this and it does kind of catch up
as we go through now for those of you
guys who were following my Marvel major
events chronology playlist which is to
say all the major events and Marvel
Comics
this will basically come before infinity
and those are the guys who were
following the events of just infinity
war and cosmic Marvel and leaving out
all the other major events like Captain
America run secret Empire things like
that this will still come before
infinity but the store but the the
playlist will still be shorter so again
not a whole lot changing there oh you'll
find both those playlists down in the
description by the way my editor Gordon
will link those down there but what this
does is it basically picks up with
shang-chi and a girl named Tamara now
initially well and again we're kind of
get kind of get into this a little bit
but with shang-chi he's really he's
super good when it comes to martial arts
but the benefit of change he is that he
kind of ties into this idea of sort of
finding your inner self right like
finding some kind of inner peace right
like he taught spider-man his old
martial arts style called the way of the
spider different things like that um
it's so Shange he's kind of the guy that
you go to when basically you you can't
solve a problem on your own and you kind
of have to meditate yourself through it
and that's one of the things that sort
of goes on here is he's basically asking
this woman Tamara like who were you
before all of this and as Tamara kind of
starts to try to recollect on things
she's getting small little glimpses of
her past she's talking about things like
well you know I don't know how long it's
been I remember being at hospital you
know I remember seeing like a flash of
light and basically Shange he says like
you've been in the hospital for 10 years
and that's when Tamara manifests back
into Captain universe now this is where
a bit of explanation comes in so in
Marvel comics you have the concept of
Captain universe and so ultimately
Captain universe basically gets his
power from what's called the enigma
force and the Enigma force is exactly
what it sounds like it's a force of
energy that basically emanates from the
Microverse but nobody knows anything
about it
nobody marvels never bother to really
explain it all but a person who's
bestowed by the powers of Captain
universe basically it only really
manifests in times of dire need right
when there's like a universal threat of
some kind but the power of captain
universe is relative and it can be
extremely
powerful or it can just be not that
powerful right like when Spiderman had
the power of captain universe he punchy
Incredible Hulk into the atmosphere this
version of captain universe is
astronomically powerful so again it's
really just kind of based on what
version of the character that we're
talking about here but basically what
captain universe says is these universes
dying like the universe is coming to an
end and it manifested itself in bonded
itself directly to that woman because
one it was a person who was available
and to this woman's situation mirrored
the nature of the universe itself
right like captain universe is a
protector of the universe the universe
is broken and dying
this girl is broken and dying therefore
it makes sense for Captain universe to
bond itself to her and so that's
basically kind of how things segue into
this now from here we switch over to
Tony Stark and we basically have Captain
universe leaving change he going to
regulate a Tony and the speaking with
Tony and Adam now this kind of goes back
to the first story arc of the Avengers
that we talked about which was Avengers
world and what we found out at least
what we saw was that there was a guy
named ex nihilo and there was a woman
named abyss and basically ex nihilo is
what was called a gardener the idea is
that the gardener's traveled from world
to world and they essentially try to
like perfect life on those worlds if
they cannot perfect life there then the
robot they travel with which is called
an Aleph destroys the world it'll just
eliminate everything on the world and
then destroy it and so what happened is
that in the first story arc ex nihilo
showed up on Mars terraform the planet
and then basically gave it an atmosphere
and vegetation and then after that he
targeted earth and what he tried to do
what he basically did is he shot an
origin bomb at earth which essentially
like jump-started the evolution of the
planet and so suddenly he had like all
these crazy growths all over the world
and different things like that but the
first humanoid to manifest itself as a
result of the origin bomb and the the
super evolutionary process that was
jump-started by ex nihilo was Adam the
issue is that Adam came out and
basically just started speaking a
language that nobody could understand
and so Tony Stark has been spending all
his time here at least a huge amount of
his time trying to decipher a language
he's never heard of before and then when
Captain universe shows up she basically
says you've got it all wrong because
Tony Stark's idea was that his name was
black field that's like the only thing
he could decipher was black field but
when when catch the universe shows off
he's like no you have no idea what
you're talking about
basically this guy's name is Knight mask
and essentially like what he's doing is
speaking something called builder
machine code and so what is up happening
as Captain universe basically modifies
the speech patterns of Adam giving him
the ability to speak English and he
simply says like it's coming and when
the questions asked
that's coming you know not man says like
it's the white event the last white
event in existence now this is when
things get really really cool is because
one ends up happening is we switch over
to something called the super flow now
when Marvel Comics what you have here
and it is really kind of strange the way
it's depicted because it's been done
different ways so bear with me here but
a Marvel Comics what you have is this
multiverse right like you got this huge
multiversal space and the way this works
is that between the universes you
basically have like barriers so think of
them like an invisible wall right like
if you if you were to look at the
barrier of the universe it would look
like it just kind of extends on forever
but if you found a way to transcend that
barrier into walk through it you would
end up in a different universe so it's
kind of a invisible wall that could only
be broken by certain people and so with
that in mind in between these different
universes it's been done one of two ways
this is Jonathan Hickman basically
changing everything that we know about
Marvel Comics because prior to this what
you had was basically just this space
between that much like having insulation
between the walls in your house that
were one room would be a universe and
another one will be a universe and the
space in between the wood you know wood
would be the insulation that's an
insulation house the group called the
many angled ones which is basically what
Shu McGrath is if you guys know that if
you don't know what the many angled ones
are they're just these giant huge
tentacle monsters that are absurdly
powerful but they're confined to the
space between universes what Jonathan
Hickman is doing here is wiping all that
away and basically saying none of that
applies anymore that instead what you
basically have is like a giant fish tank
more or less and you've got all these
different universes just kind of
floating around in this giant tank that
makes up the multiverse and the space in
between the universes is the super flow
and so basically the super flow is like
this this like these straight roads
right like 90-degree angles or I guess
curvatures or something like that but
basically what it means is like they're
essentially like straight shots it's
basically all it is but you can
transition from one universe to the next
by riding the super flow and so what's
happening is that out here in the super
flow somewhere is essentially just like
this giant device and this device is
literally being destroyed by whatever
powers happen to be out there that are
basically going through and like leading
to the collapse of the multiverse and so
what we end up doing is picking up with
like this one last really like these two
last guys that are there that are on
this structure and so it's kind of cool
here because with a conversation between
them as they start to talk about this
they start to address this what they
basically say is like there's this thing
called the white event and the way this
white event works and is actually kind
of cool is this not an original idea by
Jonathan Hickman
instead the wide event comes from new
universal from from a whole nother set
of publications that were created by
marvel but what doesn't really happen in
this other publication that was created
in this new Universal line of comics is
you didn't really have superheroes per
se he didn't have Captain America you
didn't have a man or anything like that
instead you would have this wide event
that would initiate and then like people
would be bestowed with different
abilities but the abilities they had
were relatives those of you guys who are
watching umbrella Academy
it would be like that basically in the
sense of like different people would
have different abilities but they would
come together as a singular unit and
like save the world and so what you
ended up having was like a star brand
was basically one of the first beings to
show up here but one is up going on in
this instance is that because of the
fact that like the space between them
the universes is collapsing due to the
multiversal class because it's all
basically coming to an end literally
this this singular being here designed
to kind of monitor this installation
where all these installations across all
these other universes are basically
coming to an end he basically says just
like fire just fire off a fire a shot
and just initiate the wide event and see
if we can if we can jumpstart that and
that's exactly what happens the wide
event is initiated this massive beam of
a beam of energy is shot onto earth from
this construct here and like a person is
chosen and so now the question becomes
what is the wide event and that's when
night Mass begins to comment and
basically say like the wide event is
essentially just like a dawning of a new
age of superhero and so basically like
other individuals are gonna be woken up
what night master doesn't know is the
the wide event did not go down the way
it was supposed to and so instead of
there being all these other individuals
beside himself instead there will only
be one that will be it and so what this
what this essentially does is it creates
a star brand and so again like when
night mass goes through this what he
basically says is like it's designed for
the purpose of like selecting an
individual of going through and like
selecting a person who's best suited to
contain that kind of power a person
who's the most capable and so that's
when we end up basically kind of
transition to this College this kid
named Kevin who's really kind of out
there and not really being taken
seriously by anybody and basically like
he's the one that was ultimately chosen
where Jonathan Haven initially kind of
went through and showed us like you know
some people who were jerks are like
jocks and different things like that
people who were really seeing more
traditional roles of masculine as
opposed to like traditional roles of non
masculine that basically that's what was
supposed to have happened that any one
of these guys here this jock or any one
of these guys the the super intelligent
guy they were all supposed to be like
they were the ones who were supposed to
have been chosen but it was firing off a
shot at the last minute in an act of
desperation the choice wasn't made of
actively everything was falling apart is
a failure of the system the wrong person
was chosen that this kid Kevin was
basically picked and when he was hit
with the power of the star brand he
didn't know how to control it and in the
process wiped out everything around him
literally unleashed this massive scale
of energy and obliterated everything
around him this is cool because what
Hickman does is he starts going in and
saying now let me show you the power of
the star brand and this is where things
get kind of hairy we're gonna kind of
jump ahead a little bit not really jump
ahead but kind of explain ahead a little
bit when the star brand faces off
against the Incredible Hulk the
Incredible Hulk
is immediately sent flying into the
atmosphere like literally The Incredible
Hulk has no real chance here
Hyperion shows up Hyperion's the next
one have you taken out everyone who
faces off against star brand
ends up getting wrecked and no one can
really hold off against the power this
kid possesses and the reason why is
because at the outset this is all
uncontrollable Kevin doesn't know it
doesn't really know how to control this
power he possesses or what he's able to
do but the caveat to the star brand is
that the power is is by definition
outside of Kevin's control he can
harness it but he can never control how
much power he has at any point in time
the way this works is the star brand as
a protector of a singular system as a
protector of an earth is designed to
basically have however much power he
needs to defeat whatever enemy he's
facing that's a challenge to the earth
if Galactus shows up to earth star brand
could defeat Galactus the kicker here is
that if he doesn't know how to use it
properly that he can still be killed so
it's not like it's not a one-stop shop
right like it's not an end-all answer
just because he has access to all this
power doesn't mean he knows how to use
all that power so again a guy with the
ability to manipulate reality if he
doesn't know how to manipulate anything
can't do anything with it it's useless
you know so it's like having a million
dollars in a bank account that you
cannot access it was kind of cool
because basically like Knight masks
literally like take star brand in whisks
him away and says like it's important
that you understand what your role in
this world is and it's kind of a cool
thing because when this happens it kind
of takes them on a - or basically shows
hey look this is where you got your
power from from what's now a collapsed
system the space between universes is
essentially collapsing now there's
really nothing keeping universes from
crashing into each other which we've
known all along by the nature of the
incursions but again like going through
and showing these extreme displays of
power going through and showing like
these extreme abilities is pretty cool
because it means that like for the most
part star brand is not easily defeated
when the Avengers catch back up to them
again and you've got care
Danvers Captain Marvel you got Hyperion
you've got Thor you've got Captain
America you've got the Incredible Hulk
you have all these guys facing off
against him none of them were able to
defeat him basically his power is
extreme seemingly unrivaled
and no one can really know what no one
has a chance against this kid and so
because that because this power is kind
of running unchecked the Avengers do the
only thing they can do they basically
say hey look we've got to keep the both
of you in like a safer place you've got
to keep the both of you in a place where
like you guys can't harm anyone and so
what they do and it really kind of like
Kevin and I masks actually go along with
it but what they do is they throw them
inside of a Dyson Sphere
literally like put them inside of this
cell out in the middle of space and then
basically leave them there until such a
time as one like the threat of the
incursions can be dealt with or to the
Avengers can figure out how to deal with
their powers and their extreme abilities
but again you know just kind of
continuing on to Hickman's you know
Avengers and New Avengers remastering
the whole thing and yeah so we have
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come as explained make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the
robb core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later purse
[Music]